Loren's and Louisville Kentucky hi
Lauren how are you I'm good thank you
for taking my call sure what's up I have
kind of a real estate and home warranty
question I want to know if you were in
my situation if you would file a lawsuit
against the home warranty company line
air conditioning went out and they sent
a contractor who showed up intoxicated
and very unprofessional and then a long
story short it took several weeks the
home warranty company kept telling us to
stay with this company and after paying
about for over $1400 the air
conditioning still wasn't fixed and our
home warranty company told me that I
needed to go to the contractor at this
point and ask for the money back from
and why why are you paying the bill if
the home warranty company sent them out
well it was part of the deductible that
report because a whole air conditioner
needed replaced and I guess the total is
about six thousand and so we had to pay
from out-of-pocket cost for the
contractor and the Herot the heating air
after six thousand dollars doesn't work
it finally after a second contractor it
finally was fixed on this past Tuesday
we started the whole process April 15 so
we went over 6 weeks um and so what is
the cost to you that should not have
been a cost to you well I'm just
wondering on aggravation I'm talking
about dollars okay it's a simple dollars
answer well I paid 1425 I'm out of your
pocket and you would have had to pay
that anyway if they send out a
professional company that did a great
job
you would be out-of-pocket 1425 yes and
I and I would have been fine paint and
that's not extra cost to you is there
any extra cost to you due to the fact
they sent drunks out there no no I guess
you've got been damaging you've not been
damaged financially
you've just been aggravated yeah we we
have okay there is somebody cause you're
aggravated okay okay you know why
there's no wall that pays you for being
pissed off yeah yeah I guess I more
wanted a reimbursement family company
wife first sending a well for sending
out someone that wasn't a reputable
company I agree with that but the
problem is you can go talk to an
attorney I'm not an attorney okay but I
do know basic law theory and you have
not been financially damaged
you've not long money because of this
transaction you've just been mistreated
by a horrible company mm-hmm
and I agree with you for being angry but
you asked my court yes Q would I sue
them no I wouldn't because you're not
going to get anything and if you did get
something that's not going to be much
and it's not worth the trouble lawsuit
what I would do is tell everybody I know
and you and I are telling 13 million
people right this second never use never
pay for a home warranty never buy
extended warranties because this is the
kind of garbage you get and if the thing
actually covers the thing that's broken
you go through this unbelievable
aggravation because they don't really
like to pay claims mm-hmm yes so my
sister is actually with me and has two
videos of this man who they sent would
you would you send those out and two you
know what I'm going to do is I probably
contact the contractor that was the
sending out drunk people and you
probably already done this and say you
know we're so dissatisfied we had to
have an outside company come in and we
want you to cover our deductible if you
don't give us some kind of that we are
going to let everybody know we're going
to post these videos of your gut of your
drunk now showing up at our house you
send an intoxicated out of my house
and you know you eat for that you give
it to give me a refund right and but
that's your negotiating with them it's
not the home warranty company's fault
they just did what they always do which
is try to never pay a claim mm-hmm sure
and you know you're just you're just mad
and I don't blame you for being mad but
I don't think you get money for being
mad you can call a lawyer and ask them
see what they tell you if you want to
get a further opinion and I wouldn't
blame you for doing that but you know
you just been aggravated by these people
it's a horrible experience both from the
home warranty company and from the
heating and air guy you know folks it's
interesting isn't it
people always say all those crooks get
rich the only way you get rich is you
rip people off no it's not true because
I want me to go tell everybody she meets
for the next ten years about the drunk
guys company do you think they get more
business by ripping people off no you
don't get rich ripping people off you
get rich by serving people and taking
care of business and treating people
honestly and kindly and justly and
following up and taking care of problems
when there's problems you go the extra
mile and then guess what she would have
done she just sent everybody to that
guy's business and said that guy's the
best guy in the world get your heating
and air done business is not hard it's
like tennis those who serve well win but
you know that's not going to get rich
running a business with a bunch of drunk
people going out to the house so this is
a bit this is a business that doesn't
understand they think they're heating
the heating air business oh no oh no
they're in the making Lauren happy
business and they just failed and so
Lauren is very unhappy and she should be
is she going to get money for that oh I
doubt it but you know is he going to get
rich being that way and running a
business that one no no absolutely not
horrible horrible
we hire somebody about half a second
that did something like that this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]